à montigny le bretonneux l'église de
saint quentin les sources a reçu
récemment yann arthus bertrand pour son
exposition la aux dates aussi là où date
aussi c'est avant tout une lettre
envoyée par le pape françois tous les
catholiques pour alerter sur l'urgence
climatique le photographe français
grands défenseurs on le sait de la cause
environnementale a décidé et d'illustrer
certains passages de ce texte avec ses
photos et de transformer le tout en une
exposition d'une vingtaine de panneaux
les propos recueillis par antoine durand
oui beaucoup de l'église et grizzly un
raisonnement qui m'ont demandé doit
avoir des photos dont qu'on a fait on a
imprimé des jeux de photos voilà pour
moi c'est important parce que ça porte
des valeurs essentielles qui sont des
valeurs que porte la religion
la bienveillance
l'honnêteté
c'est des valeurs jeu qu'on travaille
pas si à l'école et passer en famille
chats sont toujours bien partout où je
vais j'aime montrer mes photos et
surtout montré les légendes et parler de
ce qui se passe dans le monde
aujourd'hui quoi mais l'exposition se
déroule jusqu'au 24 septembre elle sera
ensuite observable au cap saint jacques
à guyancourt du 25 septembre au 5
octobre ainsi qu'à l'église saint-victor
toujours à guyancourt du 6 au 11 octobre